crap okay engine Springs and the chili
let the white wine reduce in a little
glaze okay minutes definitely up there
no literally cooks now how's your eye is
okay yeah yes good girl now pastors 30
seconds away from cooking okay now let's
do nicely
okay get a condor yeah get ready to
drain it passed on it okay now keep the
pan okay we'll drain the pasta okay good
over the sink and then put a colander
back over the pan good girl
all done excellence good now give a
little shake we should packet that doing
that sorry are you Lee your facial over
there yeah how come there I've touched
you understand that's like a turn-off
you know I can do it by opens well I
look a little drizzle of olive oil in
there that's what the possible so you
don't ya okay and then get your crap and
now okay it's time to mix the pasta the
parsley in with a crab I've done train
that off into the crab and then lightly
sprinkle the parsley well done nice good
in with a possible then I usual right I
made a very big mind nothing wrong with
being big getting line okay what are you
doing with your line boy I'm just
rubbing it okay rubbing it so really
sausage makers right at the soiree down
line you're watching at home and then
squeeze that lime juice all over yes
okay and this gives it really nice and
acidic Bay fresh and more importantly
just helps the crab to come alive well
done good oanh tuan the time to come
back a lot
have all right now boys out I wanna make
sure this these are good look it smells
amazing
yes right balls out you guys need to
pass it toss it a little bit okay mix up
the crab and angel hair pasta and then
take your pan to your bowl now get a
really nice portion of the age your hair
pasta over okay that smells amazing
yeah straight in Amanda that's my bowl
okay give me you've got to learn to
share my daughter warden I'm sure you've
got to serve yours you want your fiancee
standing there waiting yes now this
whole lot what's that done they get the
spoon in there I can't spoon the crab
over the pasta and I think it's quickly
just to shove it in the kitchen
shove it really watch you keep your clip
everything Tom's if I break a nail
tonight I'm gonna stick okay and replace
it just that is most amazing young angel
that's the crab to me mine done
[Applause]